hi there today i want to bring to you a
little bit of a different
video uh the video right now is supposed
to be sort of a motivational lead up to
the next video i want to release
and the next video is going to be about
facebook's new
rebel algorithm which is an algorithm
that solves
two player zero sum imperfect
information games
so it is very similar in uh to the alpha
zero algorithm or the alpha go algorithm
just that line of algorithms that
combine
search and learning but whereas
the alpha line is in perfect information
games so games where you can see
everything like chess or go the
rebel algorithm is in imperfect
information games and one example of
this is
poker so heads up uh heads up poker
like heads up texas hold'em no limit
let's say
in this case is a two player
zero sum let's assume the house doesn't
take uh rake
two player zero some imperfect
information game
which this algorithm rebel can solve
better than
apparently anything before it and
daniel nigrano who is a you know
longtime poker pro
has released these polls on twitter
which i found just to be
very interesting so the timing was very
fitting
and i thought i'd sort of make a lead up
video to
the next paper video um just to
sort of get you into the the thinking if
you've never
if you've never played poker at sort of
beyond an amateur level
i sort of want to motivate you
what makes this game so interesting
because it seems pretty simple
at the start okay so here we go
daniel negranu poses the following
question um
poker question for you all
and maybe i should briefly explain how
the game works for
anyone who doesn't know their and if you
have one minute
if you no just jump ahead one minute or
so so at the beginning
you get two cards your opponent gets two
cards
you don't know the opponent's cards the
opponent doesn't know your cards
then success successively on the board
they're going to be revealed
first three cards at the time which is
called the flop
then there's one other card which is
called the turn and then there's another
card which is called the river
and there are four betting rounds so
there's one betting round pre-flop which
is when no cards are on the table
there's one betting round
at the flop one at the turn and one at
the
river and then if the players are still
in and haven't
folded uh the cards are revealed and
scored according to the normal rules of
poker so
your two cards and the table five cards
you get to choose any five of those
seven uh to make up the poker hand
whoever has the better poker hand wins
okay
so in this situation here um
you have aces so your whole cards are
two aces which is you know the best uh
pre-flop hand
but the board is ace ak eight
four four so ace king eight
four and four so that's the board and
which gives you a full house
aces with fours okay which is
the second best hand that's possible
on this board so you have the second
best hand
now usually you would be happy to put
all your money
uh in into this board um because the
only hand
that's better than you is if your
opponent has
two fours so that is a possibility right
but it's a very very very slim
possibility um
so you might think i want to put all my
money into here but now
you know now comes the tricky part is
you put all your money in here because
you say
well there's only really one hand that
beats me okay
but you have to think ahead and say how
often
does my opponent have that hand and
crucially
crucially how often are they going to
give me
their money while not having this hand
so let's say your opponent has
an eight and a nine okay and
and so they have a pair of eights which
you know they
might think you know i have a pair a
pair is okay
um but you put in a lot of money they're
probably going to fold that hand
right so if you put in a lot of money
here they're not
giving you any money so if
now let's say they have like two kings
which is a very strong hand on this
board but
if you put in like exorbitant amounts of
money
still they're going to conclude well
it's it's not worth it
like there are still better hands i'm
going to so all of this
it's not just a question of which cards
do you have
it's not even a question which cards
your opponent has it's
it's a it's a question also of how much
money
do you put in because that regulates
very much how the strategies are i hope
i hope you can
sort of see that so you always have to
think about
what possible cards could my opponents
hold and
which of these cards are they willing to
put in
how much money into the pot and then
from that you can determine um is that
profitable for me or not
in this particular situation there are
five dollars already in the pot so all
the previous betting rounds they get
collected into what's called the pot
so the pot here in this case is five
dollars
and your opponent your opponent bets
two million dollars okay so two
million dollars on the pot into a pot of
five it's obviously a constructed
scenario but your opponent now puts up
two
million okay so you um
have to put in two million into a pot
that's now two million and five dollars
so if you let's say if you fold you lose
whatever you put in
of these five dollars so you shouldn't
think that's sunk cost anyway
you should simply think i put in two
million
in order to win five plus the two
million the opponent puts in
okay so obviously this is exactly the
reverse of what we looked at now your
opponent is putting in
a ginormous amount of money okay and you
um you have the second best hand
so this this get now gets interesting
now there is an additional complication
here would you call or fold
against the guy who always goes in on
the river every hand
okay this is an additional information
somehow you know
that this person always goes in on the
river so on the river
they always shove all their money all in
that's what you know now a lot of people
would
lean to an easy call here a lot of
people would say
of course they're going to be all in
with any like any
any time they're on the river so of
course i'm going to call it the second
best hand there are
uh many many hands and if they're going
to do this with all hands but
that's not the case they're just because
they always go all in on the river
every hand i i think this is slightly
underspecified
it's every hand where they get to the
river
right so here a smart opponent let's say
this is a smart opponent
but for some reason someone kidnapped
their dog
and threatens to kill the dog if they
don't always go all in on the river but
other than that
they are very smart player so they
they now also know that they always go
all in on the river because you know
they always go in all in on the river
so what they will do is once they're on
the
the flop and the turn they will only
ever continue
with hands where they would go all in
all in on the river right and they
they not only they not don't always have
two million
in the in on the table they might have
you know smaller
values so when they are on the flop and
when they are on the turn they are very
much aware that they have this giant
amount of money
and that they must go all in if they
reach the river so conceivably
they would fold every hand that they
weren't willing to go all in on the
river
so they they won't have just any cards
they that that seriously skews their
distribution of cards that they
could hold because they make that
inference right so now you
can sit here and say okay
it's conceivable that they actually
hold off on you know most of their cards
they would fold most of their cards on
the on the flop or turn
given that they must always go all in
all in
on the river so let's actually look at
the turn
so let's imagine we do not know that
this is
a4 right so we the last decisions are
made here
right here when it's the when it's the
turn
um here your opponent will only go to
the river with cards where they feel
that they can then fully go all in
all the way right that's because they
also know they go all in
every time they reach the river so the
question is
what possible range could they do this
with and
one possibility is like they they do it
if they know they have two million
um it's a very risky move to go all in
on the river
right so conceivably i'd say they would
not do it with two fours because they
can't possibly know that another four is
coming the chance is
so incredibly uh slim
however of course that strategy now also
changes the range of hands that you
continue to the river with so you can be
um
you knowing that the opponent will only
go to the river
with cards where they could go all in on
the river
also will change your distribution but
just
in this particular situation i would say
the following
if this is the case the opponent can't
possibly know that there's another four
coming therefore
their range here if
it includes two fours if it includes
those
it will also include something like two
kings
it will also include something like ace
four
or king four like conceivably because
those
uh maybe not but two eights maybe um
but at least two kings so so their range
is conceivably
yeah if it includes two fours it must
include two eights and two kings right
because these are
strictly better at the turn um
it could even be any ace because that
blocks you from having an ace
so if they can have fours at the end
they can also have kings and eights and
just because they can have those hands
it probably makes for
a um for a good call here on the river
because you are beating
kings and eights on on the river
uh specifically the fours are much more
unlikely because the
four is actually in the deck since we we
already know it's coming
right here so in this case i would
call um because of those whole reasoning
not because
uh i have the second best hand right i
hope you can sort of see
how this back and forth goes so you
assume that your opponent is smart your
opponent assumes that you are smart
and then you sort of reason uh one two
three levels
in depth and of course if you reason to
infinity that becomes a nash equilibrium
and that's exactly what this rebel
algorithm approximates
i would have guessed that this situation
is much more interesting if you
reverse the board so if the board was
something like four four eight
four four four four ace uh king eight or
something like this where
your opponent clearly already has the
the best possible hand uh before they
enter
the river that would make would
would make it quite a bit more
interesting i believe and i
i don't know what the analysis would be
but let's go on to the next ten so that
would be
my uh guess would be called i haven't
as you can see i haven't answered yet i
will after the video
but it's irrelevant because the most
comments i read are just like
inferring very simple things which are
as i say irrelevant so the follow-up
question here
is there same situation five dollars in
the pot
two milli opponent bets two million all
in on the river
board is the same you have aces would
you call or fold against the player you
know
nothing about okay so here is a player
you know
nothing about um now
that you know nothing about is so
now you like now you have to estimate
probabilities that the person is brain
dead
and and things like this right but
what you can do what you can do is
always just estimate sort of the nash
equilibrium
uh strategy of this situation and maybe
go with that because at least then you
cannot lose an expectation
so if you fact if you like factor in the
fact that the person might be dumb or
brain dead or something like this
then if you mess up these probabilities
you are in fact exploitable
um though you know
the exploitability only matters if that
situation happens over and over and over
and over again whereas
i think uh this is going to happen to
you
at maximum once however
same situation but your opponent
does not go all in on the river every
hand you know nothing about them right
the board happens as it is
and all of a sudden this person pushes 2
million
now let's analyze this so you might
think hey
this person pushes 2 million a pot of 5
they must hold the nuts very very very
very often
for this to be profitable right so they
probably hold
the two fours right here but then again
if you infer that you might want to go
ahead and fold
those aces okay you fold the aces
so your opponent thinks about this and
they realize
wait a minute if i can get them to fold
asus which is the second best hand on
this board
right i should probably push this much
money
a lot more often because i can you know
like i can get them off aces i can
probably get them off
most hands that they are in this
situation with right on this board a
ace uh king eight we don't know the
colors but
there are a lot of hands that get to the
river in this situation
so i can bluff them off a lot of them by
simply pushing two million in the pot
right but then it's it's this old game
you push two million to win
five dollars this has to work very often
in fact this
has to work now it has to work like four
four three hundred and ninety nine
thousand out of four hundred thousand
times uh
to break even right if it if it doesn't
work even one time
um yeah so so
if you're up if you fold anything but uh
but the absolute nuts your opponent
might actually just hold a single four
because then they know
you don't have two fours and then they
know
you can't possibly have the best hand
then it can push you off of it
but then right they if they
bluff a certain amount of time if they
don't need to bluff often
for you to actually make it profitable
and if they do in fact bluff so
let's let's assume they just bluff if
they have a four
because e they know you can't have both
fours because they have one
so you can never have the best hand and
they
think if they bet two million they can
push you off any hand
now you go ahead and you say
wait a minute if they
bluff whenever they have a single four
they're much more often going to have
a single four like maybe they have a
four
four nine or something like this they're
much more often going to have a hand
like this
than two fours just combinatorically
right so
maybe they're actually on a bluff pretty
often here if they do this every single
time they have a four
so i can actually call it doesn't even
matter that i have aces right i can
call with any any hand that hits
anything on this board is probably going
to
to beat though if they have a four they
have trips
so let's say if they bluff with any hand
i can call with any hand
and they will think about this and say
ah maybe i shouldn't bluff with any
hand right i should probably moderate
that because the other person will
adjust
if they bluff with a four they have
trip fours so um
i even if they bluff with a four i might
only
and it is a bluff like if you have a
four and you bet two million here that's
a bluff
like you're clearly trying to get
someone off of like asus
um because it's not like
you don't bet for value two million into
five dollars with this
so i will only call
with asus kings eights
ace four king four 484 stuff like this
because they all beat
a single four right um
and now the question becomes again
how so there is there is the number of
hands i will call with like
asus kings and so on
um ace4 how
these are a subset of hands or maybe not
like this as subset of hands probably a
large subset
of all the hands that i would hold on
the river like that i would get
to the river with right here and um
they are going to push me off of those
hands with with any large bed but this
this bed is really meant to get me off
of those um
strong hands so the question is how
often
do they do this with a four in order to
still be profitable so
we get back to this sort of inference of
how often can this be a bluff for me to
legitimately
call here and that factors
in how often um i am on the river and
how often on the river i hold one of
these hands that i could
conceivably catchable off with
so you can see that a lot of a lot of
stuff is going in here me personally
i would say that i know nothing about
this person
i would probably fold in this in this
case
um because if i assume they're smart
they must know that they can only pull
this
two million into five dollars thing very
very few times if they don't have the
absolute nuts
in this case and if they don't have the
nuts it almost
it almost doesn't matter what they have
they probably have a
a single four and then um
yeah the the number of hands that i can
have on the river that
are going to catch a bluff with a single
four is just too large
for them to often bluff right here
of course if we both play if
if the person plays nash optimal then
um i m i have like some assignment to
call or fall
right probability of call probably a
fold that i would do in in this
particular
situation and and then
it's going to be break even um okay last
question
though that might not be true i might
have actually a fixed binary decision
here
no because that that influences their
strategy too
yeah um last question
same thing but now
which hand would be better to have if
you choose to call
so you you choose to call but now
which hand would you rather have in that
situation would you have king 4
or aces so some people might say well
aces clearly because aces here is the
better hand
than king four right aces is full house
asus full of fours and king four
is four is full of kings um
so let's say you imagine you have king
four why would you wanna have king four
you would wanna have king four because
now
your opponent can't have two fours
anymore okay
so the possibility of your opponent
holding two fours
is off the table because there are only
four fours in the deck and
the um so so you're blocking
that possibility that your opponent has
two fours
so they cannot have the nuts possibly
they it's much more probable now
that in fact they have a
single four right and they are trying to
push you
off of something like aces you see
so it's a bit the same situation as
before and we can we can remark that
king four is also in this
hands that we would call with um
but so are the aces now
it all again boils down to what's the
frequency of them folding here and that
boils down to
what's the proportion of hands that you
have here plus what's the frequency
of them that you call with so
the question is would you rather have
aces or king 4
and why would you why would you rather
have aces what would be reasons that you
would rather have aces
well if your opponent is
smart they might think that um
and i haven't thought this through
before but let's just try to figure this
out together
your opponent so if you'd rather have
aces than king four that must mean
that your opponent would do this
conceivably with hands that you
beat with aces but not with king four
like you
you decide to call that's a given you
decide to call so now
everyone reveals their cards and
so if you say you'd rather have aces
that means you think that your opponent
would um do this kind of stuff
with something like that kings or or
aids or something like this something
that would
beat king 4 but not beat aces so your
opponent
your opponent might be smart and think
wait a minute
if this person has an f4 right
then they will think that i cannot
possibly
have two fours and
um therefore they will call with a
single four
even if i bet two million they they will
think oh
i i have the four and therefore they
can't have the four so this must be one
of those rare times where they bluff
right um and then they might say well
but i have two eights right i have two
eights i beat a single four
and therefore i can actually get
money out of anyone that's trying to
catch my bluff
because they have a single four so now
the question is
how often does anyone on the river here
have a single four
and again this is where i go and say the
board would be probably more interesting
if it was this way around
because it's much more conceivable that
anyone
has a single four lying around
if the flop was this already
though king four conceivably is you hit
the king on the flop
and then you somehow get through to the
river uh
while scoring two fours but it's just
not as likely that you still have
the four around but still you can sort
of see the thinking right so the
opponent might think
wait they're gonna call me with any old
four um especially with like
also with like king four i have eights i
beat things like ace four king four i
beat the single four
uh my opponent's gonna think i only do
the two million things
with two fours your my opponent's gonna
have a four
they will infer that i can't have a four
they will call me because they think
i'm bluffing and ta-da okay
so um you you can see that it goes
pretty pretty deep and then in that case
they will push with the eights and in
that case you'd
much rather have the aces right here
because they don't know whether you have
the four or not right
but if you have the aces again you do
not have the four
and it is very possible that your
opponent has two fours
and after all it's two million into a
pot of five dollars they would only
they have to have a very good hand very
often for this to be profitable
okay so this this kind of
thinking is is what computation
of a nash equilibrium in effect boils
down to so we're going to see
uh i don't know what the correct answer
is to this is by the way
um i the even the rebel source code
isn't open source
for poker the code is open source but
the implementation for poker isn't and
i think the checkpoints for poker aren't
uh
so um maybe we won't
we won't find out i would love to hear
your opinions on this maybe i am
completely
wrong right here but this is about what
an algorithm like that
has has to do and i hope
i've sort of given you an overview of
why this sort of games are interesting
what these algorithms need to think
about and
why it is so much harder than something
like chess or go not that the game
itself is harder but
you have to constantly reason about
things that you do not know and you
constantly have to assign
probabilities and combinatorical
fractioning how often does this happen
how often does this happen
um and then you have to adjust each time
when you adjust your strategy you have
to think that your opponent can make the
same conclusions
given the observed state and they can
also adjust
their strategy so that's the difficulty
those are the questions i would say you
go a vote see what other people have to
say and maybe daniel
will let us know uh once the polls are
over
all right so that was it for me thanks a
lot for watching
and i hope to have the next video out
very very soon
about rebel bye